la cigarette électronique fait un tabac
depuis 2010 les enseignes se développent
leur nombre devrait même doubler cette
année pour atteindre 300 le matériel en
tout ça m'a coûté 2 83 euros
en sachant que je fume un paquet de
cigarettes par jour s'il faisait 42
euros par semaine donc en deux semaines
j'aurai rentabiliser la cigarette
électronique
dans la pratique le fumeur aspire sur la
cigarette électronique comme il le
ferait avec une vraie mais ne la lui mme
pas elle ne produit pas de fumée mais de
la vapeur d'eau absorbée par les poumons
c'est la cartouche jetable ou illiquides
qui contient la nicotine et les arômes
qui vont du goût tabac authentique à des
saveurs plus insolites les red bull au
sli dans notre petit pêches abricots les
marques françaises des liquides ont du
mal à suivre les commandes des boutiques
spécialisées en recherche en tout cas
sur l'union européenne des nouveaux
fournisseurs en espérant qu'ils des
nouvelles marques qui fabrique en france
parce que on aimerait bien rester sur ce
label français ce qui est sûr c'est que
il ya beaucoup de produits qui sont
fabriqués en chine et qu'on ne veut pas
vendre ses produits chinois reste à
prouver scientifiquement les notions
d'efficacité et de risque de la
cigarette électronique
probablement que c'est certainement
beaucoup moins dangereux il n'y a pas de
monoxyde de carbone ya pas de goudron et
à tous les produits qui sont fabriqués
par la combustion n'existe plus mais
dire que c'est un produit non dangereux
pour l'instant on ne peut pas le dire
puisque ça il manque des études et une
connaissance de la composition exacte de
ces produits l'itie garrett séduit
aujourd'hui près d'un million de fumeurs
selon le dr dauzon mme berg
il vient de publier un rapport avec
vingt-et-une recommandations comme
l'interdire dans les lieux publics
après il faudrait vraiment l'argumenter
pour voir un psy et nocivité pour les
notamment les passifs mais moi je
comprends pas trop ça sans rien ça c'est
un budget normalement l'organisation
mondiale de la santé estime que d'ici
2020 le tabagisme sera la principale
cause de décès et d'incapacité avec plus
de 10 millions de victimes par an la
lutte antitabac s'accentuera le 31 mai
journée mondiale sans tabac